Der erste Kaffeefilter mit Filterpapier,
erfunden von Melitta Bentz,
1908 eingetragen beim Patentamt.
Der Melitta-Kaffeefilter revolutioniert das
Kaffeekochen und wird zum Welterfolg.
Die Erfinderin, die 35-jährige Hausfrau
Melitta Bentz aus Dresden,
gründet ein Unternehmen.
Gemeinsam mit ihrem Mann produziert
sie in Heimarbeit die ersten Filter.
Aufgrund der großen Nachfrage beziehen
sie bald eigene, größere Fabrikräume
und stellen Mitarbeiter ein.
Der Enkel der Firmengründerin,
Thomas Bentz, erklärt,
wie seine Großmutter auf die
Erfindung kam.
Die Sachsen tranken schon damals
sehr viel Kaffee,
und der Kaffee wurde traditionsgemäß
aufgebrüht.
Es wurde also Kaffee in die Kanne
gegeben, Wasser drauf und aufgekocht.
Mit der Folge, dass man natürlich
Kaffeesatz-Krümel in der Tasse hatte.
Das gefiel meiner Großmutter nicht.
Und sie kam eben eines Tages auf die Idee,
das berühmte Löschblatt ihres Sohnes
in einen Topf zu integrieren und damit
ein Filtersystem zu schaffen.
Aus Messing wird Aluminium und
später Porzellan.
Aus dem ursprünglich runden Filter
mit Filterblatt
wird eine trichterartige Papiertüte
mit dem passenden Filter.
Die Form ist bis heute unverändert.
Es wurde befördert – das ist auch ein
interessanter Gedanke,
der heute nicht mehr so die
große Rolle spielt –
unter dem Gesichtspunkt Praktikabilität
und Hygiene in der Küche.
Das waren so wahrscheinlich die drei
[zwei] wesentlichen Gedanken,
die damals attraktiv waren für die Hausfrau.
Denn jetzt wird das Kaffeepulver in
eine Papiertüte gefüllt,
die den Kaffeesatz auffängt.
Anschließend wird die Filtertüte entsorgt.
Das unkomplizierte Verfahren ist schnell
beliebt bei den Kaffeetrinkern.
In den 1960er-Jahren beginnt das
Unternehmen,
neben Handfiltern auch elektrische
Kaffeemaschinen herzustellen.
Gleichzeitig wird kontinuierlich an der
Verbesserung der Filtertüten gearbeitet.
Immer wieder werden verschiedene
Papiersorten getestet.
Es ist sehr porös, es ist relativ dick
und es ist durchlässig für Wasser,
hält aber aufgrund der Größe der Poren
eben Kaffeemehl,
fein gemahlenes Kaffeemehl zurück.
Die genaue Beschaffenheit der Original-
Melitta-Filtertüte ist Betriebsgeheimnis.
Die Melitta Unternehmensgruppe
Bentz KG in Minden
ist mittlerweile ein internationales
Unternehmen mit rund 4.000 Beschäftigten.
Heute macht die Produktion von
Filtertüten bei Melitta
nur noch einen kleinen Teil des
Gesamtumsatzes aus,
aber die Filtertüte bleibt das
Erkennungszeichen des Hauses.
Kaffeesorten mit besonders
feinen Aromen
lassen sich besser als Filterkaffee
genießen.
Filterbrühverfahren als
druckloses Brühverfahren
hat sehr viele Vorteile,
die oft vielleicht gar nicht so
beachtet werden.
Sie müssen bedenken, dass durch
dieses Brühverfahren
gerade feine und sehr zart entwickelte
Aromen der Kaffeebohne
sehr, sehr gut herausgearbeitet
werden können.
Weltweit nimmt der gefilterte Genuss
wieder zu.
Immer mehr Cafés in Deutschland
bieten neben Espresso und Cappuccino
auch Filterkaffee an.
Filterkaffee ist irgendwo die reine Form,
Kaffee genießen zu können
oder zuzubereiten.
Das ist, glaub ich, das Besondere
am Filterkaffee.
Und so wird der Kaffeefilter auch
weiterhin eingesetzt –
dank der kreativen Hausfrau,
Erfinderin und Unternehmerin
Melitta Bentz.